we know that Donald Trump's personal
lawyer Michael Cohen is in a big trouble
and it's actually very likely that he's
gonna be indicted and it's one of the
most direct paths to Donald Trump sort
of across all investigations at this
point and there's this popular narrative
about Michael Cohen which is he just has
this love for Donald Trump he would do
anything for Donald Trump he would never
cross Trump or betray Trump in any way
it is total unending loyalty to Donald
Trump by Michael Cohen which supposedly
is why Michael Cohen was willing to
mortgage his own house to pay stormy
Daniels a hundred and thirty thousand
dollars in hush money that was not to be
paid back by Donald Trump now of course
we now know that Cohen was paid back by
Donald Trump and we've also learned that
the business partner of Michael Cohen
has flipped and is now cooperating with
investigators I'm talking about afghani
Friedman who happens to of course be a
Russian immigrant known as the taxi King
he has reached a deal with the New York
Attorney General to flip to cooperate as
a government witness and this is not
good for Trump okay we don't really care
about Cohen per se or in and of himself
but it's clear that Cohen's involved in
very shady business and it's clear that
he's gonna end up in serious trouble
here the question is whether that will
reach Trump and Trump's lawyers have
already been thinking that Michael Cohen
might end up flipping because there is
just so much that the government has on
him with his business partner if Danny
Freedman now potentially telling
investigators everything as part of a
plea agreement that he has reached the
pressure or or rather a cooperation
agreement the pressure is going to mount
on Cohen and that could be disastrous
for Donald Trump and clearly if anybody
knows the bad things that Trump has done
or that Trump is authorized or the Trump
has paid for or been involved in to some
degree it's Michael Cohen and you know
that they're afraid because they've been
trying to pretend like Michael Cohen
just had nothing to do with anything at
all and nothing to do with the taxi
business that Friedman managed for them
Rudy Giuliani recently said quote he's
not just in he's just not involved in
the taxis he has as much involvement in
it
I do which is a weird thing for Rudy
Guiliani to say because it's known that
Michael Cohen is involved with that taxi
business and of course the taxi business
itself is just a small part of what
Cowan and his friends have been involved
with over the last many years but what I
want to go back to for a second is
Evgeny Friedman being Russian why do
Russians keep popping up everywhere in
this investigation every nook and cranny
they look in there's no deal that
Michael Cohen had with a sri lankan that
we ever hear about or some kind of
Chilean businessperson or whatever every
nook and cranny they look in a Russian
just pops up out of nowhere and if Kenny
Friedman is one of those guys who has
now pleaded guilty in state court and
that makes six guilty pleas so far
connected to this entire fiasco we've
got George papadopolis Michael Flynn
that Dutch guy vanderzwaan
Rick gates richard Pinet oh and now
afghani Friedman and yeah you know
they're connected to Trump to varying
degrees I would say Michael Flynn and
George papadopolis very much connected
to Donald Trump
the vanderzwaan guy less connected
Evgeny Friedman arguably not connected
to Donald Trump at all but the list is
growing and I think that when it's a
witch-hunt and you keep finding witches
you can't really call it a witch-hunt
anymore right it's just an investigation
into criminal activity and I'm
increasingly thinking about the
resignation recently of the New York
Attorney General Eric Schneiderman
because these charges against Friedman
were at the New York state level we've
talked about how the Attorney General
Eric Schneiderman of New York was
accused of sexually assaulting a couple
of women and we've known from the very
beginning of this entire Trump Russia
thing that it's actually state charges
that could bring down the criminal
enterprise of Trump and state charges
interestingly cannot be pardoned by
Donald Trump since Trump has been
operating in New York City for a long
time the most likely candidate for state
charges was always New York now I want
to be super clear I'm not saying I don't
believe the women who are accusing Eric
Schneiderman of
actual assault everyone here knows that
my instinct is my default is I believe
the accusers on principle and then I
wait to find out more to see if anything
surfaces that would question my belief
in their accusations that being said it
is very odd that the lawyer for the two
women accusing Eric Schneiderman of
sexual assault back in 2013 went to
Michael Cohen went to Donald Trump's
lawyer Michael Cohen to talk about their
allegations and then those claims became
public this year in 2018 when Eric
Schneiderman is getting closer and
closer to finding evidence of
criminality among trumps cronies and all
of a sudden Eric Schneiderman abruptly
resigns it's a big coincidence the
coincidence and I often say Pat I just
tend to not really believe in huge
coincidences I believe in odds and at a
certain point things that happen seem to
really go against the odds unless
there's more of an explanation to that
I'm a little skeptical though because if
this was all just a plan - ouch Neider
men yeah it's a little bit short-sighted
because New York has a democratic
electorate
whoever they elect to replace him would
also be a liberal but I guess it would
just throw it throw a wrench into the
whole process cuz you can delay for at
least a few months until the next one
comes around I was thinking delay was it
would be the name of the game right like
if there is some concerted effort here
among from cronies to push Sneiderman
out with the idea that that's the best
way to delay non pardonable state
charges against these people it's a
matter of delaying and who knows maybe
they'd be able to get out of office
scot-free in the meantime we're gonna
try to find out more about this and we
will see what it means for Michael Cohen
but a very very big deal and again
because every single day at 5 o'clock
it's like scandal o'clock a lot of these
stories are going minimally reported to
some degree discuss this with us on our
subreddit with more than 6,000 other
David Pakman show viewers and listeners
at david pakman.com slash re d di t
coming up next
how would you manipulate the 2018
midterms if that's what you wanted to do